Hello everyone.
This is Justin here of course at fire
of learning and I figured it was time to
make a video like this and also well
past time to thank you all for your
contribution to this channel. August
was a big month for fire of learning.
We hit 20,000 subscribers and the
history of England documentary reached 1
million views.
That is really incredible.
I could not have done it
without you guys literally,
but what I mean to say is that I greatly
appreciate you guys and I'm glad that
we've been able to form this community
centered around some pretty cool topics
this month.
We've finished the two hour long Ireland
Documentary and I've made 21 other
videos and four other documentary videos
this year so far quite simply my plan
for the rest of the year is
to keep bringing you guys
a content that you're here
to see.
One thing you guys have noticed that
I've been doing is consistently making
polls on all kinds of
questions in the community tab.
That started as just a way to
get to know you guys better,
to know who I'm talking to and also to
get feedback from you guys and it still
is,
but at this point I've been thinking of
continuing with these questions and then
doing a kind of fire of learning sense
as video where we compare the results of
all the Poles,
probably compare them to the results of
the general population and discuss them.
I hope I'm not posting too
many poles to be honest.
I'm not 100% sure how they work
from the viewer's perspective,
the channels I followed
don't do them as often,
but I just figured it'd be a
very interesting opportunity.
From what I've seen so far.
You guys have a lot of different
perspectives on the world.
You guys probably come from all walks of
life and from many different countries,
but what interests me as well is
that you guys are a group of people,
very likely,
smarter than the general population.
I'm not trying to kiss
your ass or anything there.
I'm just saying that people who spend
their time getting enjoyment out of
watching educational youtube videos
are probably not dumb people.
And so it's an interesting opportunity
I think to be able to pull intelligent
people on these big questions. A big
problem that I'm really not a fan of his,
that I'm limited to five options of pole.
I was barely able to do the religion pole
as a result of this, you know, Buddhism,
Hinduism, et Cetera, all fell
under other and you know,
I don't know how I cleanly do a poll on
something like race or ethnicity because
of this, but you know, we'll
work with what we've got.
So if you'd like to take part
in the census that I'm doing,
feel free to go to the community
tab on my channel and go vote.
And other polls because
they're all still open. Also,
I'm pretty sure these polls are anonymous,
at least I don't know how to view who
votes for what unless you comment.
So don't feel like your answers
are being watched, you know,
vote how you truly feel.
Speaking of polls and my most recent
one I asked you guys to rate fire of
learning.
The Paul is still ongoing.
I'm glad to see that the great majority
of you guys think the channel is at
least four stars,
but 12% see it as three stars
and even a couple of people,
two or one star.
As for the three stars.
One comment I got was that
I don't post videos enough.
He made this comment to be
very constructive criticism,
which I appreciate and I know
many of you feel the same way.
I am trying to be more productive with
video making and to get more videos up.
I think I am getting faster,
but at the end of the day I am just one
guy and something like the history of
Ireland videos which put together are
two hours long. It takes some time.
You know they're really 12 videos,
which are 10 minutes long put together
because of course most of you guys prefer
longer videos and I prefer
longer videos myself actually.
So I just want it to respond to that
so that you guys didn't think I was
ignoring your comments and let you guys
know I am working on more production or
being more productive because in
the end that benefits everybody,
but I did want to just say also that the
videos I make do take some time as for
the one or two star voters,
I'm not sure what the route is there.
I had one guy who voted one star comments
saying he doesn't even follow the
channel. He's never seen one of my videos,
but the polls show up on his speed,
which I don't get. But Hey, if you're
watching this, come check out my stuff.
I know obviously some
trolls fall on my channel.
Plenty of them comment
in a fire of learning.
You are a communist and arc is Nazi
trying to indoctrinate the youth with anti
white white supremacist propaganda
and I hate you and your family.
I get that kind of thing pretty usually,
but I'm still obliged to view the
responses on the Poles as serious.
So whatever your rate,
my channel,
let me know in the comments of this video
what you think I can add or do better.
Then go ahead and leave.
And the other questions,
comments or concerns you
guys have in the comments,
and I can even just get back to you
guys and the next channel update,
we can do another type
of a Q and a type thing.
So thank you all again for
taking part in this channel.
There is much more on the way.